today we'll be talking about a sagemaker
and using our Studio Pro inside
sagemaker for all of your rbase
workflows
my name is Tom Mock I'm the posit
workbench product manager and helping
with some of our Integrations to
companies like AWS and the sagemaker
platform and I'll be joined by my
colleague gagandeep later on to go
through a live demo
to start with I'd like to cover some of
the high level kind of value
propositions of what our Studio Pro and
stagemaker provides and some of the
benefits and kind of different
trade-offs that are available for that
so let's jump into this
first off we're really excited this is a
true kind of partnership that we have
with the Amazon team and the sagemaker
team and we're really excited to kind of
be able to offer our commercial offering
of our studio along with Amazon and
sagemakers platform so enabling our
customers to do this really powerful
machine learning and enhance their
workloads Beyond what's available on
their local local laptops
ultimately we can break down kind of the
benefits of sagemaker with rstudio Pro
into four topics and we'll kind of dive
into these a bit deeper
so number one our Studio Pro on
sagemaker is a managed service so this
is massively simplifies the
administration and you don't have to
have you know robust it team to manage
over everything it's managed through the
sagemaker platform as a hosted service
additionally especially compared to a
local laptop sagemaker with our Studio
Pro provides this flexible compute and
you don't have to figure out how to spin
up new servers you can actually just use
a drop down within our studio to select
different sizing of your environment for
both RAM and CPU and Etc
Additionally the sagemaker platform
comes with strict security and
compliance benefits so things like sock
2 fedramp HIPAA and additional other
kind of security confirmations and
compliance that's really useful and
needed for some of our customers in
banking or Pharma or healthcare for
example
and then lastly sagemaker also allows
customers to use their existing Cloud
budgets so for a lot of customers they
actually have budgets that are set aside
for purchasing compute through cloud
like AWS and you can use some of that
budget to purchase licenses for our
studio Pro that is then used inside
sagemaker again alleviating some of the
struggles with with purchasing or
figuring out how to get this budget
approved
overall you can kind of have this nice
little table here that compares pure
sagemaker to rstudio Pro in addition to
the core sagemaker platform
uh both sagemaker and rstudio pro on
sagemaker are flexible Computing
environments so actually backed by these
ephemeral ec2 instances and Docker
images that are loaded into it both have
a dedicated home directory for
persistent files uh R and python package
installs configuration settings
different things that you want your user
kind of experience to be the same
the main difference at this point is
that sagemaker is really like a hosted
version of Jupiter or Jupiter lab and
then our studio adds the additional our
studio IDE experience on top of
sagemaker's compute
for sagemaker with Jupiter lab you're
primarily using python so you can use
packages like Bodo 3 to interact with
AWS and different services and then in R
there's the pause r package that allows
you to do very similar things and
interact with all sorts of AWS services
in addition to sagemaker
and then lastly both sagemaker and
rstudio pro inside sagemaker allow you
to leverage a specific sagemaker machine
learning capabilities both are really
using the sagemaker python SDK or
software developer kit uh in sagemaker
you primarily call it natively through
Python and then in our studio you
actually wrap some of the commands in R
using the same sagemaker python SDK but
wrapping it with the reticulate r
package allowing you to call python
directly from r
so really the the environment is the
same for both of them but providing kind
of a different user interface with the
same packages and persistent files
behind the scenes
as far as a lot of the customers that
we've seen um kind of be ideal fits for
our studio Pro and sagemaker number one
users who are already invested or are
investing in the AWS ecosystem so maybe
they're already using sagemaker but want
to leverage R there and really like
using our studio or maybe they're using
our studio on a desktop and want to make
use of the robust machine learning
tooling and scaled compute available
inside sagemaker
additionally because sagemaker is a
hosted environment and the AWS team is
actually managing the infrastructure for
you users who lack it support or don't
necessarily want to commit the resources
needed to maintain a fully custom
environment can go through this with
kind of a ready to go spin it up kind of
very quickly environment
and then lastly really emphasizing that
for our studio desktop users at a
certain point your laptop or even your
workstation is going to run out of
compute maybe you need 64 gigs or 128
gigs of RAM with sagemaker you can scale
up kind of as large as it'll allow you
to go and then whenever you're done you
can actually shut down that environment
and stop accruing cost so you have these
kind of cost efficient scaling out as
needed
as far as some of the additional
benefits of our Studio Pro on sagemaker
you know since again our studio is a
managed service customers don't have to
really worry about managing
installations of R and python or even
installing a posit workbench slash our
Studio Pro itself in the environment
it's already kind of ready to go
additionally our software product called
launcher is working behind the scenes
with sagemaker internally that allows
you to create these individually sized
and isolated sessions so you can have a
gigantic session run a model leave it
running and then go to a much smaller
session with say like eight gigs of RAM
and then do some computation there
exploratory data analysis while your
large model training is occurring
additionally our Studio Pro on sagemaker
has direct integration with identity
access management through AWS so you can
use a lot of the other AWS services
without needing to re-authenticate or
move around a whole bunch of credentials
kind of log in once and use a lot of
other different things
you can also use again these
pre-allocated Cloud budgets so it's
pretty often that we see some of these
customers have a lot of you know money
tied up into their Cloud budgets and
they can use a small portion of that to
purchase these are Studio Pro licenses
to be used within sagemaker
and then lastly reiterating that for
some of our compliant and secure needs
of customers that sagemaker already has
sock 2 fed ramp HIPAA compliance and is
adding additional compliance um kind of
certifications over time
I do want to call out some of the
trade-offs or differences though between
a self-managed positive workbench that
includes our Studio Pro as well as
Jupiter lab and vs code versus our
Studio Pro on sagemaker number one you
know self-managed deposit workbench
provides complete flexibility about how
you set up and configure and administer
workbench you do need an IT admin but
you can really set up a really custom
environment and have access to all these
different things you need
this does come at the cost of kind of
responsibility you do have to have that
it admin Persona to come in and maintain
update the environment and the
infrastructure but if you really want
that customization that's a good route
and you can run it through any a Amazon
ec2 instance or even use clusters such
as ECS for kubernetes or parallel
cluster first learn on AWS
importantly our studio on sagemaker is
this managed service so the
responsibility for the software and the
environment resides with AWS you
actually work through the AWS support
team as well as in some cases the
positive support team if you're into
trouble instead of the individual
customer kind of only working through
their it admin
and lastly you know while posit
workbench has access to multiple editors
it has our studio it has vs code as well
as Jupiter and Jupiter lab the sagemaker
environment has the rstudio IDE as far
as the rstudio pro integration and then
Amazon sagemaker studio also provides a
managed kind of Jupiter Jupiter lab
experience it does not have the same vs
code integration that posit workbench
does
so there are some different trade-offs
and just kind of design decisions as far
as what you want if you want this really
custom environment and kind of set it up
exactly as you want or you have
different needs you can self-manage or
install your own software into
traditional infrastructure or you can go
this fully managed route through Amazon
sagemaker
before I turn it over to my colleague
I'm also going to share some of the
resources so if you do have questions
about getting started with sagemaker you
can go to posit.com sagemaker this has
all the information about getting
started with our Studio Pro on sagemaker
maybe doing a free trial where you can
evaluate its use for your team or you
can even talk to a salesperson here or a
colleague at uh posit to talk about
doing some of the integration work as
needed
with that I'm going to pause stop screen
sharing and turn it over to my colleague
gogandeep who's going to cover some of
the more technical details and the
Integrations and show off some demos
about how to use AWS and our Studio Pro
together
awesome thank you Dom uh hi everyone I'm
ravindeep Singh I am a senior solution
engineer here at posit and today I'm
following up Dom by showing you off on
how to use this R Studio Pro integration
from within stage maker
so to begin with I land in my in our own
internal sagemaker domain which is
maintained by us and then I can enable
the asked video IDE from within that
sagemaker domain now in your case uh
this will look different on how you
reach the rstudio indication it will be
managed by your AWS ID admins
and they will share a domain with you
but after they've enabled our studio in
it so once you have logged into AWS and
access that domain you will see the same
screen that I'm seeing
so now this is an R Studio workbench
learning within the sagemaker domain so
it's not on my computer I'm accessing it
through a URL and this is an additional
screen I get since I'm using the
professional product through which I can
run multiple sessions uh of our studio
uh in the sagemaker domain at the same
time
I can start a new session by using the
new session button I can give it a name
right now as Tom mentioned uh only
option to use is the rstudio IDE so I
have no choice here and this is running
within the sagemaker environment so the
cluster is also fixed as sagemaker the
options I can change according to my use
case are like are these instant type and
images so by instance type I can choose
which ec2 instance to use for this
current session so this is the
flexibility that you get by using
rstudio within sagemaker it is directly
integrated into the EC tools into the
AWS environment so I can choose an ec2
based on the type of work I'm doing so
if I plan to do a minimal Eda data
analysis just create some plots explore
some data I can choose a smaller size
instance and if I'm planning to bring it
bring it bring in bigger size data to do
a high heavy lifting in modeling I can
choose a bigger size of instance this
flexibility only comes by using
something like AWS and our studio is
integrated into that
I can also change the docker image that
is being used to run this session so
everything is running as a Docker image
as a topic container there is a default
image available but I can also customize
what kind of images I want to use so I
can work with my administrator to create
a Docker image for different kind of
workflows so if I have a requirement of
using certain versions of packages or
certain system dependencies in that
environment I can create different
images for that
for this work I am just using the
default instance type and the default
image which I've already started a
session here so once I go into the
session this R Studio sessions looks
very similar to what you used to if
you're using the desktop version but it
does come with additional flexibilities
of using the professional version I am
going to run through a small example of
building a machine learning model on a
sample data set
where I'll be predicting the John at a
cellular company based on their customer
data if a customer is going to turn or
not so I've already prepared the code
and I'm going to run through it today
I'm using a markdown and I'm doing some
uh to begin with I'm setting up my
environment uh I'm using the public
package manager provided by posit
through which I can get package binaries
uh in this session so you can also
customize your repos to get binary
packages from the public package manager
that will make the installation easier
so I've done that setup and I'm also
loading the different uh libraries that
I'm going to use so I'm going to run
this bunch of code
while this is running
um I can see that I already have the
data set available that I'm going to use
for this book I have saved it on my uh
in my session the in the home directory
that is attached to the session so I
have moved it here already and I am
going to bring it in into the session in
the turn data frame so I've read that
and I'm going to explore the data so
this is what my input data on the model
looks like I have information on the
customers which state they belong to how
many days for their account with us
um the area code how many days minutes
have they spends on how many calls they
make per day all that information
associated with cellular information
I also have other features that are
available like how many minutes they
take on call how many calls they have
made to the customer service if they
have an international plan or not and in
the end if they have children or not
with us so this is my input data set and
I'm going to predict
um build a model to predict the children
for for our Consumer Voice
so before I before I begin with the
modeling I would uh as a good data
scientist would like to explore the data
that I'm working with I want to see like
what are the different patterns I can
observe what kind of features I can use
with feature combinations that will help
me later in building the model I want
so I'm going to select the international
plan and then plot it and see how many
people who have churned actually have
used an international plan feature so
this is a histogram showing that the
number of users who have churned have
they had an international plan or not
the data here looks pretty even so not
much to gather out of here
let me now create a histogram with how
many customer service calls they have
made so it is an assumption that if
somebody is churning they might have
some complaints about the service they
are getting so if I create this
histogram this is what I get for people
who have churned I can also change the
variable and see the same information
for people who have not churned how how
satisfied they are based on that this is
like a few examples of doing this kind
of exploratory analysis yeah like
there's plenty of feature sets I could
have played around with but for the sake
of this call and the workflow I'm going
to stick to these before I jump into
modeling I would like to prepare my data
for the model so right now the data is
pretty
um
untidy in that sense so I'm going to
tidy it up and these are some of the
Transformations I'm doing I am first uh
just filtering out the lows which have
churned the customers who have churned
then I'm going to use I plan to use XC
boost in this case so I'm going to
prepare my uh repair some dummy
variables on a voicemail international
plan the state they belong to and I'm
gonna move the children variable uh to
the front of the data frame so that like
I can divide the test and trade for so
I'm just going to quickly run out of
this code
while this code is running uh this so
far I have been doing what I generally
do day to day as a data scientist uh
either on my desktop or somewhere in
another professional server product but
the advantage of doing this here is that
my compute is flexible so my data set
currently is not that big if but if I
had a bigger data set and I was bringing
uh like millions of rows into this
session for doing this kind of analysis
I could increase the size of the compute
instance I'm using behind in sagemaker
so this helps me with the flexible
compute but I'm still an art programmer
so I'm still using what I know in R but
I'm doing it in a scalable manner
now that I've prepared my data set I am
going to divide into test training
meditation and then as part of this code
block and also saving it as CSV files
for future reference
currently this is saved in the file
system attached to this session but if I
clear out this domain or something
happens on the AWS side I might lose
this data
so one of the things I could do or I
would want to do is move out this data
the input data from my model into a more
persistent place which is not like the
file system attached to this session and
a common uh data service to be used in
AWS for that kind of work is S3 buckets
so I will need I can interact with S3
packets from within my code in a more
efficient manner than a usage Network
and that is what I'm going to do next
once I've written those files
in order to interact with this sagemaker
session that is running uh this R Studio
instance I will use the sagemaker python
package which is what Tom the salute
into before so if I want to interact
with different AWS resources like S3 or
directly with the sh maker service which
I can do that through the sagemaker SDK
now this is the python SDK so you will
have to use the credit Public Library if
you're not aware ready for API CU
interact with python packages directly
from your environment so and in order to
do that I do need an existing python
installation running along with this
session so I will use the terminal
feature within R Studio as you can see
I've already done some work
but I've already installed python into
this session by using
um like the python binaries uh you this
is a session this is a python version
that works for me but if you have
requirements on certain python versions
that you can use you know all obviously
install it for your session
I need this python session to also have
um the sagemaker python package
installed so that I can import it in
this session so I will use like a tool
like web to install the sagemaker
session savemaker package and I've
already pre-prepared this session to use
that so if I run the library reticulate
it will attach that and it will import
that sagemaker package here
oh now the sagemaker is attached now I'm
going to use the sagemaker python
packages internal functions to proceed
and this requires you to know what
sagemaker is as a service so I'm using
the sagemaker functions to access
uh information related to the session so
I need to create a session object and I
can also
um there's always an S3 bucket attached
with a sagemaker session so I'm going to
use that S3 bucket as my place to keep
all my data so I'm I need that
information I can directly get it from
the session object as well
and also while creating this domain uh
every domain needs an execution role in
a sagemaker and this is set up by your
administrator and then through this
execution role they can give you
permissions from the AWS side to access
different resources so I have always
every session in sagemaker every R
studio session has an execution role
attached with it and I can access
information for that role as well
now through this role is uh how I will
access things like S3 so if this was not
um sagemaker and I was doing this in um
my desktop environment I would have to
explicitly provide the AWS secret keys
and all this credentials I need to
access AWS but here in this case I
already have a role attached to the so
as a user I have one less responsibility
and I don't have to worry about
maintaining credentials or any security
risks that are associated with it like
everything is native within sagemaker so
I can directly interact with S3 and this
is exactly what I'm going to do and now
I'm going to save my uh training testing
and validation data set into this as the
market that is attached so again as you
can see it was pretty simple then using
desktop I don't have to maintain
credentials there's already a role and
I'm using that role to access S3
another way so far this was done through
the stage maker session that I'm running
problematically by using the python
package there's also a native r package
if you're all not familiar it's a great
package for pause which provides the
options to access
S3 or other AWS services natively and
also that also requires setting up AWS
credentials but in this scenario I am
already within the sagemaker AWS
environment so I can directly use pause
uh to access all the all the AWS
resources so as an example I will show
you how to read the same uh data that I
pushed or put into the default S3 bucket
and now I'm going to read it through
pause so I'm going to create an S3
object to pause and then just read that
file and then
type of work
I
so this is the same file I put in I can
read it as well so interacting with AWS
resources is very simple and again I can
use any other AWS Services as well
either through the sagemaker SDK which
is in python or directly to pause if I
know the function I want to use
now that I've played around with data
saved my data make sure it's persistent
and I have the training and testing I
want to build the XT boost model so I
can either use the native tidy models or
anything I'm familiar with but since
this is an instance of our studio
running on sagemaker I can interact with
the sagemaker service as well so
savemaker service all has pre-built
models available that you can use on
like any size of data because it's a
flexible way of running those models
these models run as containers so I can
optimize the size and select based on my
input data I can select the variability
there so I am going to use the same
sagemaker python API that I've already
loaded to build this XC XC boost model
directly into sagemaker so I'm in
sagemaker I can directly access it so
I'm just going to run this code this is
just preparation for that model and
these are all Sage maker API specific
commands so this is a need to remember
and know what you're working with but
there's great documentation available uh
from sagemaker on how to use this
and here I'm going to build a container
that will use the XD boost framework
from sagemaker and I'm going to give it
the location and all like my role
um what is the input type is what size
of ec2 instance it should run on so I
can optimize that as well I can also
give it hyper parameters
um like I want to use logistic
regression and 100 times I want to run
that XD boost tree again these are all
settings that you can optimize based on
your workflow and again these are all
flexibilities available within sagemaker
so once I have done that and I have
prepared the XC boost model I need to
start the model training which is run
through this command so this takes quite
some time so in order to save the time
already I have already trained the model
beforehand but this is the command
you'll use
and once you have trained the model on
the input data set you will have to
deploy it on sagemaker so that you can
interact with it this will give the all
Model A Unique identifier to be used
either within this barcode or any other
service any other language can access
that so I also have deployed that model
so it says that these are the outputs of
that and in order to see where the model
is you can go to the sagemaker UI within
the sagemaker UI you can see this is the
model I've deployed the XT boost model
and you can also test or work with it
you can get get its Arn if you want to
interact with it from outside of
sagemaker as well within sagemaker you
can make it part of your different
workflows so now your model is built in
R but as available in Sage method as an
endpoint
now that I've done this I can make
predictions on the same model I can do
it either programmatically also the UI
so this bunch of code already does that
I already have these predictions based
on the actual value I bought is the
predicted term and I can validate that
by creating an Roc curve as well
so this is the modeling workflow that
you can use with sagemaker and then once
you're done with the endpoint you can
obviously delete it if you want
or you can keep it up and running based
on your useless
so this modeling workflow so far relies
heavily on knowing the sagemaker service
natively but as an R user like if you're
coming in from desktop versions that's a
difficult entry point so there's also
another alternative workflow available
for you which is through the r package
called whatever if you have not heard of
edible it's a machine learning framework
that helps you
build your models natively in r or
Python and then deploy it on different
endpoints either on positive connect or
AWS Edge maker so you can you don't have
to rely on sagemakers API but if you're
within Sage maker whatever can help you
is
and deployed as well so for deploying a
variable model the process starts with
actually building a model so I will I'm
using again I'm using a different kind
of model here to formatable I'm using a
logistical version but whatever supports
uh all possible models within tiny model
so you can choose again based on your
workflow your your own selections you
can define a model that you want to
deploy I have this logistical regression
model and then I need to convert this
into a virtual model object so that
whatever I can interact with it and this
is what I'm doing
and whatever needs uh the model to be
pinned so that it can iterate on
different versions of the model uh so I
will use the pins package here uh same
S3 bucket that I am using for my data I
can use it for my model as well so I'm
using the same bucket and using the
vertical pin right function to pin this
model
on the same default bucket that is
associated but if in your case you're
interacting with some other resource
like positive connect you want to say if
you're paying on positive connect or
another S3 bucket you can change that
and save that too
now this is where like I would say the
selling point of using whatever in the
scenario is whatever has the whatever
deploys H maker function already
available which does all the hard work
of what we have done in terms of the
deployment so far so you don't need to
know the sagemaker mortgage you can all
directly use this function which will do
all of the stuff for you so I will
provide it the board where the pinned
model is what is the name of that pin
again the same instance type I want to
run it on any other additional arguments
and what this
whatever deploy sagemaker function doing
is doing in the back end is it's doing
three things for you which is what we
did uh step by step already to the
sagemaker API so it will first build the
docker image needed to run this model
and then it will change it or deployed
as a sagemate or create the sagemaker
model and then it will also deploy the
endpoint so all these three steps that
you can also do separately but this
function is doing it for you so this
only I need this line of code and this
model that I have locally will be
converted to a sagemaker mod and already
deployed on sagemaker again to save us
time I've already done that deployment
and any like the other model that we
already deployed my writable model is
all sort of deployed and
for me to interact with so this is a
great way to get into working with
sagemaker if you don't know the
sagemaker CLI but you do know whatever
which uses the basic ID models and then
there are multiple ways to get into
sagemaker and then this workflow now can
be extended to create different other
workflows within stage maker since I've
already done the
so this is all what I had and I wanted
to show and I'm going to pass it on back
to Tom to talk more about this thanks
for your time
so as we kind of wrap up for the day
I'll go back to this slide around the
resources that are available so God can
walk through kind of a bunch of
different ways that R can be used and
our studio can be used inside sagemaker
both natively from using some of the
sdks and software tooling that sagemaker
provides as well as some of the tooling
that we provide here at posit through
things like tidy models and vetiver
if you're interested in learning more
about sagemaker you can again visit
posit.com sagemaker for an overview or
even to schedule a call to talk about it
with us and then goggin and I will also
be here in the chat and can take some
questions and and questions from you all
here that are viewing about sagemaker
and some of the Integrations that we've
done with our studio
with that I'd love to thank you again
for watching along with us we'll take
questions now and we'll see you soon
help me